yeah welcome to this video something out
of the ordinary I'm posting a video Yeah
right in the middle of my summer break
which is about 25 weeks have been way
two weeks for pure holiday not doing
anything much just relaxing but now i'm
up to traveling to Poland tomorrow for a
tournament but I'm taking this
opportunity of one days at home where
I'm mostly just doing yeah washing
clothes and preparing for for the new
trip I want to use this time because I
can of course Lee and do recordings at
home which is not so easy on the road to
post you or keep you updated that's the
right word right phrase but my book
project if you go to www mmhs comma
publishes page you now find my book in
there yeah in the new and upcoming
titles which means there has been
substantial progress yeah good news
really it's a um actually that's a new
update from yesterday I just I just saw
that on here from 29 yeah the book C&M
so and boo goo Indian now shipping to UK
and European retailers from our
warehouse so my book is on the way it's
done it's printed everything's fine it's
on the way to them do the online shops
where you can where you can order it um
and on the everyman chess.com page you
can also click on the book here and yeah
that's the cover pretty nice so it
actually is an image opposition yeah
it's a initial position of the news oh
and they also have a sample a PDF
extract here if you click click and then
you can actually read something or this
book so you can see the the chapter
structure it fits go 400 400 40 pages in
at the end
you can read the intro and some some
stuff here from the from the section on
the ruin Stein variation so 26 pages if
i'm not mistaken so the book is ready it
is printed and if you're really yeah
interested in an opening book on that
subject yeah it's it's it's around the
corner the book and the thing is what is
a bit unlucky is that I'm away on my my
chest related trip while it will hit the
hit the stores and i'm not i'm not
around I'm only back in about what is
this yeah close to accuse to get two and
a half weeks then I'm then I'm back um
the thing is I actually always intended
to give some books or sell some books
why on my channel two people interested
who wandered signed with some yeah
dedicated line they're like this book is
formed mr. mm-hmm and yeah signed by me
um I guess they are friends and they've
got many people writing writing to me
who are interested in such a signed copy
of the book and I want to do that but
because i'm away until the i think it
will be the 18th or 19th of july i
cannot do anything before that so if you
are interested in such a signed copy
directly a purchase buy from me it will
take a while simply because i have to
get back and i'm currently in talks with
the publisher when i get some some
copies for for that purpose so it's kind
of a kind of an unlucky situation if you
really need the book badly and and just
want to have the content yeah you can
just buy it from the various online
sources yeah sites like new in chess
como in Germany there are a couple of
distributors where you can you can get
it here for you
one shot that I constantly uses this one
this I ish are calm from from a friend
of mine um he's got it listed as
upcoming um but it's a matter of a
couple of days when it is in the shops
if you needed badly use one of them one
of those sources if you want the book
from me with with a dedicated yeah this
was my signature and everything in it um
it will take a bit of time probably from
from this day on like three or four
weeks it's impossible to do quicker
because I'm not around and yeah so you
need to be a bit patient that if you
want the book like that if you are
interested in such a signed copy um I
will definitely keep you updated on this
subject on the channel even if I'm away
um and if you are interested please send
send a mail to to the mail address that
I'm posting here or I'm mentioning here
in the video description that will have
in the in the video so that I can get an
idea how many copies yeah I need your
order from the publisher it's a kind of
useless devour order lag and fifty
copies and only ten ten people are
interested or something like that so
please send me a message even if you did
so before cup lots of people did in the
past month and and India since this
project has been started but please even
if you did send me a mirror once send me
a new one so that I can just check what
happens in my inbox over the next two or
three weeks to get an idea what's
happening there yeah also if you are if
you did not know about the project have
a look at the PDF sample it's a good
good extract giving you an idea what is
this all about yeah I hope you enjoyed
this this is update this piece of
information and i'll keep you posted and
even when i'm away maybe I don't have a
video camera everything but I will
definitely send out some information
over the channel
on updates for example on updates when I
might be able to send out sign copies or
how how this is done probably a payment
would be rye a paypal and I would yeah
only I would only charge of course the
the standard retail price maybe a small
fee for the for the Postal for for the
costs for sending out but it won't be
like an or 50 bucks or something it's
just like I think 26 zeros or 25
something is the standard retail price
and I won't charge much more maybe like
28 or something to get my costs covered
okay well thanks for watching that video
and yeah please let me know not in the
video comments please but but by mail um
if you are interested in such a signed
copy thanks